in this video we're going to study the
electric field created by an infinite
uniformly charged plate and why are we
going to do that well one because we'll
learn that the electric field is
constant which is neat by itself and
then that's that's kind of an important
thing to realize later when we talk
about parallel charged plates and
capacitors because you know our physics
books tell them that the that the field
is constant but they never really prove
it so we will prove it here and the
basis of all of that is to figure out
what the electric charge of an
infinitely charged plate is so let's
take a side view of the infinitely
charged plate get some intuition so
let's say that's the side view of the
plate and let's figure out what it's and
let's say that this this plate has a
charge density of Sigma and what's
charge density just says well that's
Coulomb's per area all right charge
density is equal to charge per area
that's all charge charge Sigma is so
we're saying this has a uniform charge
density so before we we break into what
what may be hard core mathematics and if
you're watching this in the calculus
playlist you might want to review some
of the electrostatics from the physics
playlist and that'll probably be
relatively easy for you if you're
watching this from the physics playlist
and you haven't done the calculus
playlist you should not watch this video
because you will find it overwhelming
but anyway let's proceed so let's say so
once again this is my my infant so it
goes off in every direction it even
comes out of the video where you know
this is a side view and let's say I have
a point charge up here Q right point
charge Q so let's think a little bit
about if I have a point let's say I have
an area here on my plate let's think a
little bit about what it's what the net
effect of of it is going to be on this
point charge well first of all let's say
that this point charge is at a height H
above the field so let me draw that this
is a height H and let's say this is a
point directly below the point charge
and let's say that this distance right
here is R
so first of all what is the distance
between this part of our plate and our
point charge what is this distance that
I'll draw in magenta what is this
distance what is that distance
well Pythagorean theorem it's this is a
right triangle so it's a square root of
this side squared plus this side squared
so this is going to be the square root
of H squared plus R squared so that's
the distance between this area and our
test charge now let's get a little bit
of intuition so if this is a positive
test charge and if this plate is
positively charged the the force from
just this area on the charge is going to
be radially outward from this area so
it's going to be it's going to look let
me do it in another color because I
don't want to it's going to go in that
direction right but since this is an
infinite plate in every direction
there's going to be another point on
this plate that's essentially on the
other side of this point right over here
where its net force its net
electrostatic force on the point charge
is going to be like that and as you can
see since you know we have a uniform
charge density and the plate is
symmetric in every direction the X or
the horizontal components of the force
the horizontal components of the force
are going to cancel out and so that's
true for Furley any point along the but
along this this plate because if you
pick any point along it we're looking at
a side view but if we took a if we took
a top view if that's the top view and of
course the plate goes off in every
direction forever and that's kind of you
know where our point charge is if we if
we said oh well you know there's this
point on the plate and it's going to be
you know it's going to have some Y
component that's in on this top view
coming out of the video but I'll have
some X component this points X component
affect will cancel it out right you can
always find another point on the plate
that's symmetrically opposite whose X
component of electrostatic force will
cancel out with the first one so given
that that's just a long-winded way of
saying that the net force on on this on
this point charge will only be upward
right I think it should make sense to
you that all of the X components or the
horizontal components of the
electrostatic force all cancel out right
because there are infinite points to
either side of this test charge so with
that out of the way what do we need to
focus on well we just need to focus on
the Y components of the electrostatic
force so what's the y component so let's
say that this is exerting let's say that
this point right here and I'll keep
switching colors let's say that this
point and once again this is the side
view is exerting a it's field at that
point is let's say the electric field at
that point is I don't know ee1 right and
it's going to be going in that direction
what is its Y component what is the
component in that direction and of
course it's pushing outwards if they're
both positive so what is the Y component
what is that well if we knew theta if we
knew this angle if we knew this angle
the Y component or the upwards component
is going to be the electric field times
cosine of theta right cosine is adjacent
over hypotenuse so hypotenuse times
cosine of theta is equal to the adjacent
so if we wanted the vertical or the Y
component of the electric field we would
just multiply the magnitude of the
electric field times cosine of theta so
how do we figure out theta
well that data is also the same as this
data from our basic from our basic
trigonometry and so what's cosine of
theta cosine is adjacent over hypotenuse
from sohcahtoa right cosine of theta is
equal to adjacent over hypotenuse cosine
of theta is equal to adjacent over
hypotenuse so when we're looking at this
angle which is the same as that one
what's what's adjacent over hypotenuse
this is adjacent that is the hypotenuse
so what do we get we get that the Y
component of the electric field due to
just this little chunk of of our plate
the electric field let in the Y
component let's just call that you know
sub one because this is just a little
small part of the plate
it is equal to the electric field
generally the magnitude of the electric
field from this point times cosine of
theta which equals the electric field
times the adjacent times height over the
hypotenuse over the square root of H
squared plus R squared fair enough so
now let's see if we can figure out what
the magnitude of the electric field is
before and then and then we can put it
back into this and we'll figure out the
Y component from this point and actually
well not we're not just going to figure
out the electric field just from that
point we're going to figure out the
electric field from a ring that's
surrounding this so let me give you a
little bit of perspective or draw it
with a little bit of perspective so this
is my infinite plate again I'll draw it
in yellow again since I originally drew
it in yellow so this is my infinite
plate it goes in every direction and
then I have my charge floating above
this plate someplace at a height of H
and you know this point here this could
have been right here maybe but what I'm
going to do is I'm going to draw a ring
that's of an equal radius around this
point right here so this is our let's
draw a ring because all of these points
are going to be the same distance from
our test charge right they all they all
are exactly like this this one air point
that I drew here you could almost view
that this is a cross-section of this
ring that I'm drawing so let's figure
out what the O the Y component of the
electric force from this ring is on our
point charge so to do that we just have
to figure out the area of this ring
right we just figure out the area of
this ring multiply it times our charge
density and we'll have the net the total
charge from that ring and then we can
use Coulomb's law to figure out its
force or the field at that point and
then we could use this formula which you
just figured out to figure out the Y
component I know it's involved but it'll
all be worth it because you'll know that
we have
constant electric field so let's do that
so first of all Coulomb's law tells us
well first let's figure out the charge
from this ring so Q of the ring it
equals what it equals the circumference
of the ring times the width of the ring
so let's say the circumference is 2 PI R
2 PI R and let's say this it's a really
skinny ring it's really skinny it's d
are infinitesimally skinny so its width
is d R so that's the area that's the
area of the ring and so what's its
charge going to be its area times the
charge density so times Sigma right that
is the charge of the ring and then what
is the electric field generated by the
ring at at this point here where our
test charges well Coulomb's law tells us
that the force generated by the ring the
force by the ring is going to be equal
to Coulomb's constant times the charge
of the ring times our test charge
divided by the distance squared right
well what's the distance between really
any point on the ring and in our test
charge well this could be one of the
points on the ring and this could be
another one right and this is like a
cross section so the distance at any
point this distance right here is once
again by Pythagorean theorem right
because this is also R this distance is
the square root of H squared plus R
squared right it's the same thing as
that so if we want to do so it's the
distance squared and that's just that's
equal to K times the charge in the ring
times our test charge divided by
distance squared well distance is square
root of H square root of a squared plus
R squared so if we square that it just
becomes H squared plus R squared and if
we want to know the electric field
created by that ring we just the
electric field is just the force per
test charge so if we divide both sides
by Q we learned that the electric field
of the Ring is equal to Coulomb's
constant times
charge in the ring / h squared plus R
squared and now what is what is the y
component of the charge in the ring well
it's going to be this right what we just
figured out is the magnitude of
essentially this vector right but we
want its Y component because all of the
X components just cancel out so it's
going to be x cosine of theta and we
figured out that cosine of theta is
essentially this so we multiply it times
that so e the d the field from the ring
in the y direction is going to be equal
to its magnitude times cosine of theta
which we figured out was H over the
square root of H squared plus R squared
and we could simplify this a little bit
the denominator becomes what h squared
plus R squared to the three-halves power
and what's the numerator let's see we
have K H K H and then the charge in the
ring which we solved up here so that's 2
Pi Sigma R 2 Pi Sigma R make sure I
don't lose anything 2 Pi Sigma R dr so
we have just calculated the Y component
the vertical component of the electric
field at H units above the plate from
and not not from the entire plate just
the the electric field generated by a
ring of radius R from the base of where
we're taking this height and so I've
already gone 12 minutes into this video
just to give you a break and myself a
break I will continue in the next but
you can imagine what we're going to do
now we just figured out the electric
field the electric field created by just
this ring right so now we can integrate
across the entire plane we can
essentially take the we could sum up all
the rings of radius infinity all the way
down to zero
and that'll give us the sum of all of
the electric fields and essentially the
net electric field H units above the
surface of the plate see you in the next
video